oh okay it's uh it's just barely past
one o'clock uh we're gonna convene the
division three work session
um we're we're all we're all here
representative uh nordgren is is not
going to be able to be with us today and
we have a representative Weiler uh
sitting in for now
um so so we're now open and
um
first order of business I think we're
going to just jump right into hearing
from the commissioner
the the point of having the commissioner
come and lead us off was to just give us
an opportunity to hear from her directly
on how she describes uh her priorities
and I I don't necessarily mean you know
Financial priorities but the Strategic
priorities of of what services her
Department provides that are that are
key that we need to have an eye on and
then of course there are budget
implications that we should try to align
and support the commissioner's
strategies where we can so uh
would you like to come up and get
started and can somebody confirm for me
that we're on YouTube that it's worth
streaming
good afternoon Lori Weaver interim
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services thank you for having
us today
I stole Nathan's presentation he has
paperwork so then he took it back I was
trying to find mine and Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um so just just to start off um I I just
want to contextualize the information
that we're going to present to you today
um so before you we have a high level
overview of the department and the
purpose the goal um from my perspective
today is first to talk about uh to your
point representative Edwards
um first to talk about what what the
commissioner's vision and strategic plan
is and you'll see that in the first
couple of slides some of these will look
a little familiar just from the last
time just to just to make sure that
we're all on the same page and then
afterwards we're going to talk about
each of the division level or agency
level areas of the department and and
the respective divisions and also touch
on what what do we expect to be points
of discussion uh in the in the upcoming
meetings that we have scheduled over the
coming weeks as well as provided this as
an opportunity for you know if you do
have some initial questions you know we
can raise those today if I can't answer
them today I can get I can bring those
back if there's additional presentations
that you haven't seen on the agenda you
know that that you would like to have
before the committee
um you know I'd like to start to
schedule those in now so we can do all
the prep work to make sure that we can
be responsive to your questions and get
those answered
um so with that I will hand it over to
the commissioner
thanks Nathan
so as Nathan said I I will talk about my
roadmap as I shared with you um I think
it was a couple weeks ago I do have some
more detail on that as promised from the
last time but just starting out for from
the beginning obviously we have our
mission
um of the department breaking out in
terms of some basic functions and the
responsibility slide is really when you
think about the department it's large
budget and all of the responsibilities
that it has we break it down into the
four areas of Education delivering
services to clients protecting the
health and safety of our citizens and
Regulatory oversight so there's a little
bit of example under each of those of
what that looks like that's probably the
most succinct way to break down what we
do I could probably sit here for hours
and tell you everything about the
department but at that high level that's
what our focus is the page after that
the slide after that is our
organizational our current
organizational chart for the office of
the commissioner as you can imagine we
have multiple organs organizational
charts so if you were to look at the
division of program integrity and
quality that would then break down into
its own
organizational chart and I will share
with you that all of these are on our
internet so should you be curious to see
how something else breaks down you can
just go into our website
and get that level of detail providing
this level of Office of the commissioner
for this presentation that we're doing
with you today so that you get an
understanding of how we sort of break
out our more administrative operations
which is on the left side and then on
the right side you'll see most of our
policy areas and there are some
administrative areas underneath as well
such as the financial and the legal
sections may I ask a question about this
wire diagram I I I know that this is the
first budget that we're under the office
of the commissioner there is the
established the prescription drug
affordability board and I think it's
under your legal and Regulatory could
could you just point out where they
all the way down to the bottom right you
'll see the chief legal officer right
underneath that is Licensing and
Regulatory services so it would be under
that org chart there
where it says Doreen Shockley thank you
Mr chair question uh representative Hill
thank you thank you
um so in this organization chart right
ripsum is in charge of dcyf but my
understanding is above and beyond the
staff that directly report to him right
there's other staff within the
department some are which under the
commissioner itself in terms of like
Legal Services other things beyond the
legal services department is there
anything else
could you clarify anything else that
reports to Joe no no that works on dcyf
stuff that is within right that is not
underneath him directly I know like I
know the legal department right from one
of the orphan charts I saw along the way
reports up through the office of
commissioner
so if you look at this chart here if you
were to go to the left and you'll see
there's program quality HR
Communications Information Systems
facilities all of those support every
single box on the right and then if you
go further if you go down you'll see our
chief medical officer as well as our
Nathan our Chief Financial Officer our
chief legal officer finance and
procurement those also support all of
so in terms of looking forward in
priorities
um I think as I've mentioned I'm interim
commissioner that I know of for at least
a year so perceived until apprehended
and this is my plan my focus is the
roadmap so looking at four commitments
I've been socializing I socialized with
with you a couple of weeks ago I've been
out and about to various groups
including our staff to socialize that
with them as well if you if you go to
slide six this is sort of the the
bubbles are the summary of the four
commitment areas which pretty much break
down to Workforce managing our time our
resources effectively and organizational
value which is pretty much return on
investment and promoting thriving
communities is really working in a lot
of our service delivery areas so at the
time that I met with you I if you go to
the next slide I had talked about four
commitments the four commitments break
down into 11 initiatives high level
actions that will lead to goal schools
so we have 11 initiatives that have 28
goals and I counted this morning 97
deliverables
as of this point in time so that is
going to be our Focus from February to
February and with an evaluation process
that is ongoing with dashboards and
measurements as well I could talk a
little bit about the commitments a
little bit more starting on slide slide
eight uh no surprise to anybody that
Workforce is an issue it's an issue for
a lot of our providers in the community
it's an issue for the Department as
you've probably seen with our vacancy
rate even though we have positions we
can't fill them if we do fill them
they're turning pretty quickly so
attrition is happening quicker than we
can fill so our Focus really is one to
build up the workforce and two to keep
the people that are there there and to
provide Career Development opportunities
for people to stay in the department
Department's pretty large you look at
that org chart you see different policy
areas you could come in one policy area
grow and still have an opportunity to
apply in another policy area so it's a
pretty good place to work in terms of
opportunities but on top of of you can
hire people you can get people to stay
but one of the key ways to get people to
stay is really focusing in on your
culture so when we think about
psychological well-being we hear about
that a lot right we hear about
compassion fatigue we hear about our
First Responders we hear about people
you know those that that are doing the
caring being worn down and we also know
that our communities are dealing with a
lot of mental health issues so we're
making an effort and a push in this next
year to really focus in on creating a
space that people feel valued their work
is recognized and their work is
Meaningful right so the work that
they're doing is making a difference in
the lives of those that we serve that's
part of our mission so we're going to be
focusing in on that so when you look you
think about the initiatives we have
multiple goals in that area and
deliverables that will speak to that
can can I jump ahead a second
um
on the deliverables as I flip through
your slide deck I don't I don't see the
97 deliverables I I know that they're
probably somewhere
they're right here in my hand oh okay at
some point if you could you know
transmit that because as we hear folks
coming in uh to to brief after you what
I'd like to be able to do is is to take
your strategies and map their budget
requests just so I can get some
assurance that we're we're all lining up
that your strategies are being resourced
and and and when the I.T guys come back
I'm going to be wanting them to map
their I.T efforts into your your
strategies as well and I don't I don't
know if you find that helpful but that's
that's that's one of the things I think
we want to try to do is align the all of
our efforts absolutely I mean I think
this morning at fiscal one of the items
approved from Das was on Recruitment and
getting new tools so that's actually one
of my deliverables is to be able to have
access to those tools to make some of
the changes here so it is a lot that
that is an example of it lining up
Nathan will make sure that we get that
to you it's going to be posted on our
intranet and intranet my point being is
that we want to share it with whoever's
interested in reading it so absolutely
and to anticipate one of the standard
questions if we could have it in an
Excel form I don't know what what the
underlying document is but if we could
have a soft copy of it and not just a
sure
um if I'm okay to move to Commitment too
uh so commitment two is promoting
thriving communities
um so when we you know people say well
what is that how do you break that down
it's really looking at
um Equitable care Equitable access
increasing access modernizing improving
a lot of our systems so this isn't
necessarily new work this is lifting
that work up and bringing some
intentionality with how these things
work together so it's an alignment of
systems of delivery which is which is in
line with a lot of the efficiencies that
I'm trying to gain with this so in terms
of looking at what we do and having it
more integrated as well as Behavioral
Health Continuum we need to increase our
Behavioral Health Workforce we know that
that is an issue and we know that a lot
of the systems that we stand up it's
great but if we don't have the people to
run them then we don't have a system so
focusing in on that things like critical
time and intervention you may or may not
have heard that ways of trying to keep
people in communities rather than in
restrictive settings if they don't need
to be and the juvenile justice system is
really you know that does include what's
going to happen in the future with our
with our Juvenile Facility but it's more
than that it's really about assessing
kids before they get into the criminal
justice system before they're getting
into the courts and seeing if we can
meet those needs in a community-based
way so we have what we call a cans
assessment a child an adolescent needs
assessment our assessments have
increased significantly over the last
year kids are getting services and not
necessarily having to be placed in a
residential facility or Correctional
Facility I'd like to ask you a question
about that I I think that's a great
objective that we all share
Mr ribson has shared some data overviews
with us where he says that New Hampshire
is depending on how you interpret the
statistic we're either number one or
number two in terms of the lowest per
capita incarceration
of Youth and you know let's assume that
that's correct
with that it seems to imply is our
ability to reduce the head count
further is is going to be challenged and
not that we shouldn't keep making
efforts to reduce it but what what is
your sense on
um what he's offered in testimony that
we we
probably have to realize that there is
some natural number
where we just can't get below that in
terms of managing Public Safety and and
and and taking care of these kids too
sure and I don't I don't want to debate
the number with you there's there's
numbers that go back and forth I think
we've gotten it low I think if we can
keep more kids in community we will but
could we go as low as six I don't know
if we could ever really say that when we
look at our census and we look at the
laws that have changed and the kids that
are going there
um I think the number that we've a lot
of people have landed on is around 12 12
to 18 seems to be the number but I don't
really think it's 18 I think it's
probably hovering right between 12 and
15 but that could change with anything
right I mean if kids aren't getting what
they need that number could go up
so it's I agree with what Joe is saying
this is uh pretty much our return on our
investment so uh we had a an executive
order and I think it was back in it was
right prior to the pandemic that
basically was asking us to stay or
directing us to stand up a division that
would really look at program quality and
integrity covet hit we we have we had
the the infrastructure up we had some of
the positions but wasn't fully developed
it is my intention to get that fully
developed to basically have a framework
for quality and Performance Management
across all of those policy areas so
something that's a little bit more
standardized I know marathellius was
here talking with you a little bit about
that as well so that is we will be a
huge Focus for us as well as our
contract lifecycle management so that's
really the key word there is life cycle
so it really starts at the conception of
an idea for a service which which you
know involves the people that are going
to be bidding on the server so right so
people that are people that are doing
the work coming together in terms terms
of talking about what the need in the
community is so that we're writing
procurements appropriately and correctly
where having contracts that hit the mark
and that we're constantly monitoring
them and at the end of the day that
contract Service did made the difference
that it was supposed to was a service
that was provided so yeah I mean those
are things that you say we probably
should be doing absolutely I don't have
enough staff right now to continually do
that but it is a need so this division
will help Propel that for the policy
areas work with the policy areas where I
say policy areas that's divisions we
have seven major divisions as well as
provide that technical assistance for
folks so that we can get to a spot of
so just to make sure I'm mapping your
words here into what I understand in the
organization this is where uh Meredith
tell us or tell us okay
um are you I assume you you're familiar
but I hate making assumptions with the
conversations I've been having with her
for the last two or three years where
um I I think under the previous
commissioner she had intended to to
really do what you're doing now is is
making this Quality Function
um vital to being able to produce good
metrics so that we know what resources
to put in and whether or not those
resources are being effective those are
kind of two different issues but that
the pandemic threw everything off so so
what I've been saying to to Meredith is
that
um I I support I think on on basically a
10-year program and we're in kind of
year three is from my viewpoint of of
developing that into a very robust
capability so that uh Future Finance
committees when they're trying to figure
out how much resource we should invest
in your system we've got we've got
really nice work workload metrics to
look at and then when we ask the next
question is these resources we're
putting in are we getting out of this
what the quality the results that we
want and have those metrics my
understanding is the state of of your
department now is that you you you are
doing a pretty solid job on the contract
side but internal to the department
that there's still a lot of work that
that you see that could be done still to
develop those kind of metrics is is that
yes one is that a fair assessment of
your of your
status of the maturity of this and and
and and two
um
would you
do you share sort of that long-term View
yes I I don't
know it on are we in year two or year
three of a 10-year plan but you we are
trying to build that infrastructure now
so that we can have those things
consistently across all pop program
areas right so I would agree with you we
have it uh We've
done a great job with the procurement
process but it's that life cycle
management piece of it right we've got
the front end we need the rest of it we
do it well in Pockets we need to do it
well everywhere
okay so when that part of the budget
comes in we're obviously looking at the
next two years but if I had some sense
of where you see this rolling out to
year 10 whether we're in year two or
three now I I don't much care but if if
we could just see sort of your long-term
road map to to get to where you really
want to be because I don't think you're
going to get to where you want to be in
this budget cycle are you no I I would
that'd be great but no I don't I don't
think so all right thanks yeah I think
we'll see the return on that probably
the fourth commitment
um there's a little bit about kind of
ties in what we were just talking about
is really if we have limited uh
resources which we do and high demand
how do we manage that effectively so
really one of the things I'm working on
uh we're ready to roll is a project
governance structure which allows the
senior leadership in the department to
look at the priorities and and align our
strategies and resources with those
priorities pretty intentionally
um and part of that is our best project
management best practices which we've
have implemented some new tools over the
last year and it's actually the return
on that investment has been pretty good
we know that what we have for tools and
processes work for that so we're going
to blast that department-wide the the
third bullet here is really again
knowing that we have staff shortages and
knowing that part of the work that we do
is 24 7 facilities as you can imagine
we're short staffed not only clinically
but also what we call Environmental
Services all of the support services in
a facility really intentionally aligning
some of those resources to improve
operational efficiencies
took a question here
um Am I Wrong to think that for now at
least the um
the secure forensic facility is should
you should be listed in as one of these
items or or is it just embedded already
into New Hampshire hospital
it's currently not I mean obviously we
know it's not built yet so we don't
exactly have we're not that point yet it
will be but this is if we're looking at
12 months which is what my roadmap is
sort of that time frame I think you
would see that after that okay so I I
think you've actually tweaked my
thinking about it I I thought that what
exists and operates now in the prison
within that bubble area of the prison is
this is the secure forensic unit now
doc no no so the forensic hospital that
we are in the process of getting ready
to put out for the forbid for the
architect for the construction that that
will be attached to New Hampshire
representative Wallner
just a quick one but um program that's
now
is that
um yes and I can call I've asked for
that to be called out actually no that's
not I'm sorry so Hampstead Hospital and
residential treatment facility that's
one uh that's their new that's their new
acronym hhrtf the path program should be
in here and it's not it's a mistake
oversight that it's not in here great
thank you I've been saying all week when
I've been presenting this and paths
should be included in here and I thought
I thought the edit was made and it
okay
so those are those are the commitments
those are the focus and I I those should
be lining up with as you were indicating
you know as groups come through I think
you'll find our our different program
areas who are part of developing this
you will find alignment in many of those
can I go back and ask you about culture
I I I want to make an assumption about
part of your
objectives for maintaining and improving
the culture of the department
um
that as as we're building it and as
you're continuing to support your vision
for everyone uh I I assume you've got a
very
patient or client-centric view that the
Department's purpose is to send to to
support that end point those those
people who live throughout the state and
that it's vital to helping those people
to have a strong provider Network that
doesn't necessarily that doesn't for the
most part report to you at all but still
they're part of uh this the total system
and you're although you're stuck with
some informal responsibility there it
still seems to be the Department's
responsibility to have the whole
department view that extended system as
part of what's important to you
absolutely yeah our Pro I mean are you
honing in on provider
well I I I'm just I just want to make
sure as we're going through the budget
that we're prioritizing monies that help
people who directly touch patients that
that there are priorities might
certainly my priority because that's the
most direct way to ensure that patients
and clients are getting the services so
I'm I'm very biased I think towards
wanting to support everything that's
kind of a direct care item
sure so so if we go back to the org
chart just for a second I would my
response to that would be I agree with
you I mean everything that we do is for
those that we serve knowing that
probably 50 is going to of this of the
population or the workforce is going to
be directly involved with that then we
have all of these administrative
operation areas that we that you asked
about
um those if we don't have you know the
the funding in those areas obviously we
can't do the work on the front end so
there's the back end there's the front
end and then the provider end yeah I
mean we really don't have you know a lot
of a lot of what we do is is earmarked
for that population but sometimes it may
not come across that way at the end of
the day right when you get to the very
end it is about those those that are
receiving their service even though it
you know I assumed we were aligned but I
just I hate making assumptions on
something like that
um and and you have mentioned that you
you do have a requirement or you see the
requirement to rebuild a culture that's
been hit by remote work and and the like
and a lot of attrition so as long as
we're focusing on the elements of the
Health Care system that don't operate
inside the formal structure of DHHS
alone I I think that's the place we want
to be for the state
absolutely I mean we can't do it without
our providers right there's only so much
that we can do so it's internal and and
external all right thank you we'll pick
up where you want to on this
one I'm going to hand it off to Nathan
great thank you if you turn to slide 12
um there's a very high level overview of
the Department's State fiscal year 2425
Governor's recommended budget there
um we've we've talked about this
previously in in some of our prior
conversations but as you'll see our
department we're approximately 49
federally funded that is a vast majority
of the funds that we do receive about 31
percent are General funds and the
remaining 20 is other funds and
um when it comes to the other funds we
will be I'll actually be talking about a
couple of those today and then next week
in the subsequent week we'll really dig
into some of the details of what those
other funds represent because in each
division area they're going to represent
something very very different
are there any questions on slide 12
question
thank you Mr chair
um you've given us excuse me you've
given us numbers for 2024 and 2025. do
you know what for as a benchmark was
this year for those three sure
so for State fiscal year 2022 we were
approximately 2.8 billion dollars for
State fiscal year for the current state
fiscal year 2023 we're approximately 2.9
and then
of course and I'm going to talk about
some of those cost drivers here in the
coming slides
so you you weren't here last budget
cycle but one of the things that Mr
Ripple worked out with your predecessor
was
um as we looked at numbers we we added a
couple extra columns to the left hand
side of the spreadsheet so that we had a
six or eight year trending of the
numbers and to representative Hall's
implied Point here is just seeing what
you're projecting for the next two years
doesn't give us the context that the the
the the deeper materials will
um but we'll we'll be getting to that
of course yeah and again the attention
of this slide wasn't necessarily for
comparative purposes but more of a high
level overview
um and and the subsequent slides will
have that that prior actual adjusted
authorized figure available
um
slide 13 of the the purpose of this is
is I wanted again I'm really thinking
about starting everybody off at kind of
the 30 000 foot View today what I wanted
to do was just kind of highlight where
the positions are within DHHS and
starting on the left you'll see the
division for children youth and families
there are a lot of direct care service
providers
um and and HHS employees providing those
Direct Services and that's part of the
reason why you have a higher number of
personnel there we did abolish 50
positions uh and from that division this
past through this process and those were
primarily at the SUNY New Youth Services
Center we've seen a reduction in census
and those positions weren't going to be
filled so we reduced those given the
current census levels
the next um
if you shift to the right you'll see
Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility the positions that
are represented there those are six new
unclassified positions for for this
budget they were approved
um through this past uh legislative
session and process
um but those are new we also have
approximately 21 classified employees as
well that we will be seeking to convert
to full-time authorized positions
currently they're full-time temporary
positions and that was that was more of
a result of the state acquiring a
facility Midstream and converting some
of the some of the existing positions
that hand some existing Personnel at
Hampstead into the state system to
ensure that we have the operations staff
on site
the division of economic stability this
is an area I think Bureau of family
um excuse me
um this is an area where we also do have
some Direct Care Providers these are the
individuals that are conducting
eligibility uh determinations and
processing and answering questions for
individuals that that are seeking SNAP
benefits or other benefits as well that
is certainly a large function there the
division of Medicaid services well it's
it's relatively small on the FTE front
you will see from a budgetary
perspective this is the team that
handles the the MCO contracts uh so you
know even though it's only 32 positions
it's actually handling a a significant
chunk of dhhs's budget
the division of Public Health Services
and we'll talk about this in a little
bit this is an area where we have 72
accounts so we have a lot of federal
grants with each Federal grant we often
have a separate accounting unit and many
of these individuals here they manage
those Federal Awards on an ongoing basis
the division for Behavioral Health
approximately 58 positions there the
office of the commissioner and
representative you I'll talk about this
a little bit more in detail just about
what the support looks like it's
approximately 544 authorized positions
Glencliff home 24-hour facility there's
169 positions there 695 at New Hampshire
hospital another 24-hour facility as
well and then the division of long-term
supports and services yes representative
Edwards do you have a question I do and
maybe you're going to get to this right
regarding the office of the commissioner
in the 544 listed here I'm looking at
the a different org chart that was
provided by Mr Ripple
doesn't sync up to the exact number but
it's close right Office of the
commissioner probably from the prior
year maybe it looks like the vast
majority of these Physicians are
classified right meaning hourly workers
and I'm not sure why we would have such
a large group that is typically
full-time staff that are what I would
consider
to use the colloquialism white collar
workers right that would be office
manage office staff in a typical
organization that would be hourly as
opposed to more traditional salaried
people
so so your question is why are they out
yeah why why why such a large percentage
of
right administrative
oversight type help that is there all
the time very consistent jobs as opposed
to Direct Care being in fielded workers
where hourly might make more sense well
they're both our own
so I'm not sure I'm understanding your
question so I would see that the admit
the department that's helping out the
behind the scenes that has the same
workflow in and out all the time right
where those would be hourly over salary
doesn't seem to make sense to me
from the traditional business corporate
model right those are positions that
have very similar jobs day in and day
out you can plan weeks in advance what
the workload is going to be which is
different than let's say the case
manager who suddenly gets an extra case
or has a case that takes an extra amount
of time right it's it's you can't plan
the caseworker workload as well as you
can the the support staff behind the
scenes sure I mean I think the bigger
picture is how we get positions right we
don't get we don't really get a choice
of would you prefer classified versus
unclassified I.E salary versus hourly
right we get a Workforce with positions
that we then structure into an
organization and we only have out of
that whole total number of positions 87
are unclassified and those are usually
your upper management positions but for
HHS they're also cited in statute as
requirements for positions that we need
to have so we don't have more than that
and to make an ask for that that is a
legislative ask or another change to
establish something so and most of those
positions are represented right so
they're covered uh with by Union as well
whereas unclassified aren't okay so we
just don't have a lot of flexibility or
Choice with that I guess what I'm saying
to you
follow-up so so
in the perfect world I'm gonna live in
the perfect world but in the perfect
world would it make sense to have a
greater a greater percentage as
salaried staff versus right versus
hourly for some of those jobs
no I mean you would take some of the
front-facing staff to encase management
and one would say look at their overtime
and look at their comp time and would it
make more sense that they're salaried
and not hourly
caseworkers are in a different rate it's
hard to predict what the case load is
going to be week to week but I'm
thinking the support staff whether it's
the I.T side there's a bunch of other
things that are going on behind the
scenes and maybe it's just having spent
so many years in the corporate world
I I right the people on the on the line
that are making the widgets right those
are the people that you might have an
extra order in so you need to have
people there and they need to work
overtime I get it and that's equivalent
to the caseworkers but some of the
administrative staff tend to be more
behind the scenes and very consistent
week to week work world-wise
so I I and we'll we'll talk about this
next week but
um what sometimes should be consistent
is not consistent at all because we get
you know if it's on the legal side we
may get right to know requests we may
have a case prop up if it's on the I.T
side there may be an emergency if a
system is down there's generally
speaking it it I I don't know if I would
necessarily qualify a lot of that as
regular work okay
representative Waller did you have a
answer but
um
instead of the Hands-On work where a lot
of the Hands-On were done by the
department is done by contracts with
contract agencies do we have any idea of
how many employees are out there working
with
Health and Human Service clients but out
in the community through a contract this
so I think that would be a difficult
figure to come up with we we create a
separate budget for every contractor
that we have and when they submit their
invoices they have to submit supporting
documentation that attributes the cost
that they're requesting reimbursement
for to to whatever whatever they spent
it on
um generally some of our contracts we
can see this is one position this is two
positions uh you know our psychiatric
contract at New Hampshire hospital we
can see how many uh psychiatrists you
know we have on staff so in those cases
it's a little clearer in some of our
other instances where we may pay on
deliverable or something along those
lines that's going to make it a little
bit more complicated so you may be able
to come up with that but probably not
short of several hundred hours of
analysis
please don't waste your time doing that
could I follow up
um
so do we have in our Contracting with
all of these outside agencies do we have
requirements
um around their pay scales around the
benefits provided to their employees are
they required to have something
I currently no we we do not so when we
go out to bid whether it's a request for
proposals or requests for bid or a
request for applications we don't
necessarily specify the amount that that
contractor that organization needs to
pay their staff sometimes if we do a
request for proposal we'll evaluate both
the technical component and the cost
component and through that cost
component analysis we will see what's
the you know what's the cost per nurse
or something along those lines but
there's not necessarily a requirement
that if they budget at that cost that
that nurse is paid at the level that
they had proposed
um necessarily there you know there's no
uh representative Stringham yeah do you
have a I think you mentioned 400 major
contractors that we work with was that
approximately correct number so
um the numbers that were provided last
time had separated them into kind of two
distinct categories
um I believe there was roughly over 200
contractors that are providing Direct
Services to the department and the 400
number were the contractors to your
point that were providing services on
behalf of the department
and and Dewey is a list of all of those
provided at some point I can certainly
provide a list okay absolutely thank you
may I just add something to to your
question I was just sort of roughly
adding up in my scratch math here of how
many in the department you know we're
probably just shy of the 2000 positions
when we take all of our 24 7 facilities
but then we take all of our case workers
which we consider direct care right so
so a more than half of our staff are
so while we're still on slide 13 here I
I look at this slide totally differently
than most people I look at this and I
try to listen back to what I've heard
the I.T folks talking about about how
leveraging it can help us with the
productivity gains and to somebody like
me when I hear productivity gains I'm
hearing can can we reduce Manpower while
still doing the job so as I look at this
um I'm I wonder
which of these towers are most likely to
be influenced by good I.T implementation
to either make it more productive or at
some point give us some bandwidth to to
relook Manpower allocation
Office of the commissioner
Office of the commissioner when we look
at everything that's in there right we
let's just take requests a right to know
requests right we know that technology
can help us streamline in that process
and and get that information out quicker
it's going to be a lot of your
administrative operational areas that
are going to utilize the technology I
mean to my point there's 1900 staff
providing Direct Care there is
efficiencies with case management
technology but in terms of the work that
we did this past spring looking at what
technology can bring efficiencies where
we're short staffed a lot of it was in
our operational areas administrative
operational areas
so so that sounds like if when the it
folks come in they'll be talking about
what they're doing to try to streamline
the 91a process or those kinds of things
so that what you're saying and and what
they're doing to help you you're it's
all aligned
yes it should be I mean you know made a
request for for money to be able to do
some of that that doesn't mean we got it
so we are doing some of that but it's
important that we have the technology to
do that so it they will be speaking to
that asks of that yes all right thank
you uh representative Earth thank you Mr
chair this more request than a question
related to this chart could you also
provide the temp full-time breakdown and
the part time breakdown and also how
so all of the positions here are I
believe are are funded I I will verify
that and get those other numbers for you
okay so something other than a one
dollar
so
representative's question got me
thinking
I I tend to think of our Manpower in
five buckets
um full-time part-time
um
temporary permanent that's sort of four
of the categories depending on how you
associate them and then the fifth bucket
are contractors
and so
and my right to interpret this is really
just being the the permanent full-time
or is this permanent and temporary
full-time and and do and and to
represent a verse question do we need
um a a broader lay down so we see better
how the Manpower is allocated so this is
the total authorized full-time positions
that you'll see in the governor's
recommended budget at the bottom of each
agency section or even at the bottom of
each account you'll see the the position
count and that's what this represents
and this represents the classified and
unclassified positions that have been
authorized within the budget the
temporary full-time and temporary
part-time those are typically what
you'll see in the governor's recommended
budget those are typically represented
within class 50 and class 59 that's
where those typically would show up I
can talk to the data team to figure out
how we could do some sort of
visualization of that just for the
committee's purposes
thank you representative do you do you
have a follow-up there
no that'd be great I mean really I
understand it's a snapshot because
you're part-time and temporary full-time
are definitely shifting around but I
just like to have some some sense of how
they break down of course
representative Stringham do you have a
question yeah so I I thought I
understood
um you know the last presentation it's
not inconsistent with anything you said
now but
um you know if you look at uh you know
managing the services you provide if you
compare us to other small states uh
where you know hiring people and having
them be your direct temp or or full-time
uh people is a much bigger percentage of
the spend uh and
um then
um then contract Contracting if you
could you know we generally are
Contracting a much higher percentage of
our budget and our services and the
Health and Human Services then then all
of the comparative states that we looked
at and if that's correct then you know
when we're we're looking at uh
you know trying to generate efficiency
we have to be looking at both sides of
those things not just employees direct
employees
um uh I guess first is did I hear you
correctly on that with those two charts
that you created and is that a
reasonable conclusion the the charts
from the last presentation
yeah so so the the charts from the last
presentation those were pulled from the
consultant report and I can certainly
provide a link to everybody if if you'd
like to take a closer look at that and
when they were looking at
um our Department of Health and Human
Services as a whole they they were
finding that we were a little bit more
lean
um but but when we when we start to go
through some of our accounts in detail
you'll see that some of our Contracting
lines
um or our class 70 class 74 grants or
our 102 our Contracting line you will
see that those numbers will often be
much larger than some of our Personnel
costs
um yeah so if I think I remember like we
often are spending 450 000 per employee
and some states were half of that level
but the con but it's heavily loaded
contractor just like you said rather
than salaries yes I can't recall those
numbers off top of my head but roughly
yes
I I just want to clarify that that
comparison was for States that had
similar Medicaid populations that we did
I I think I think we beat 13 to depth
are you ready to go all right on to 14.
um so I I just based on the conversation
that we had last time um I took a look
at the governor's recommended budget and
some of our position costs and I I just
threw in a couple of of high-level
numbers here um so we did have a net
reduction of 20 full-time authorized
positions
um I won't go in the details there
unless you want to hear them
um and and when I looked at our total
budget our Personnel cost ratio for
total funds is about 10.5 percent of our
total budget and of our general fund uh
Personnel cost was about 5.2 percent
um we'd also discussed a little bit
about the DHHS so we're about 42 percent
of the budget and we represent the
full-time authorized positions not the
temporary part-time approximately 20 29
of all state positions
um just for kind of higher level context
if if you turn to slide 15
um this is the office of the
commissioner and beginning on Tuesday uh
legal and finance will be presenting in
the morning well and in the afternoon
we'll have the office of Health Equity
um HR and others come in that day and
then later in the week on Friday we'll
have facilities and it present as well
and I I think it's important to
understand that within the office of the
commissioner you know we do have our HR
our finance our procurement functions
our privacy our security our Medicaid
recoveries our Fraud Unit uh Meredith
toulouse's team is here as well
um but but it also includes Information
Services it also includes licensing and
and we'll be talking about this on
Tuesday licensing for child care
licensing for Health Care Facilities so
it's not just kind of your traditional
administrative support
um it includes quite a bit more than
that I don't know if there are any high
level questions on the office of the
commissioner before I move forward
I do
the federal funds really seem to be
jumping big right is it seems like the
federal government is trying to
downsize its Financial investment in the
States on on the health care basis
so what what's going on there that's a a
it doesn't look like we're bringing in
more money because we're matching more
because the the dollars from 23 to 24
and general funds stays about the same
but yet the feds jump what what can you
explain that yeah there's a couple of
things that are happening there off the
top of my head we had about a 1.3
million dollar increase in our federal
funds for our office of Health Equity
for our Refugee population there's
roughly a six million dollar increase in
our class 27 line and Dave weeder is our
director of Information Services we'll
be talking about that on Friday
we also saw oh we also centralized our
our sway cap and this is our Statewide
cost allocation plan so what that is is
the Department of administrative
Services charges each agency a certain
rate for General administrative costs
and you'll hear swycap which is it's not
intuitive acronym by any means but this
year we actually centralized that those
costs into ocom and a lot of those costs
are cost allocated so there's one
another kind of contributing factor for
why you're seeing that Federal fund
uh you know coming in just a second it
it seems like this is the opposite story
of what we were hearing two years ago
but it could just be my memory that that
that that that that we we had gone
through a period of transition in the
funds to where
um uh I I thought we had sort of
decentralized a lot of expenses to get
it allocated better to the Departments
and this sounds like uh if I'm
remembering that right this sounds like
a reversal where we're reconsolidating
and and before you answer I'm going to
let representative talk because he he
knows his stuff better than I do
okay so so
will you tell me if I if you know our
history on the decentralization and the
reconsolidation am I right on that or
not I don't know what trans
is it relative
well
relative to admin Services fees or are
internally to HHS the it was all an
accounting issue within DHHS where uh
that one of the complaints I remember
from two years ago was it was hard to go
measure a department year to year to
year because the the allocations of what
went into the each account was changing
so you you never really had an apples to
Orange comparison and so so I just sort
of swallowed it thinking okay this is a
period of transition and stability now
now it hears it sounds like maybe we're
still transitioning back and forth we're
in apples to oranges comparisons is
going to be there
so I didn't hear the prior discussions
but um this past summer when we were
putting our budget together I had made a
decision to centralize those costs in
one place just for that reason because I
couldn't clearly see across all of the
different agencies how those costs were
being uh whether you know to be able to
see the trends that's part of the reason
hold on a second Mr rippler are you
listening and paying attention I I want
to put you on the spot you know to to
correct my memory or or verify it you're
right we did have those conversations
last time but I think that's something
that tends to happen with HHS in every
budget cycle there are always uh
inconsistencies in terms of comparing
the budget from one division to another
division for example because there's
there's a lot of movement from year to
year within that department
so it did happen last time but I'm
it's probably going to continue
happening
so it's going to happen next time too I
would guess so all right thanks
representative
this isn't my question but I
agree with what you just said that it
seems like we changed CFOs and they
change how to do the accounting because
the previous one was going the other way
going out into the
groups so that it's interesting that
we probably should find a stable system
and like lock it down for the
legislature regardless whether it's good
or bad but as a quick question just on
this slide here regarding the general
funds what is the jump between the uh 22
actual and the 23 adjusted authorized
so if there were if there were contracts
that were encumbered but no funds were
spent in that year that would be carry
forward and so if there were delays in
certain projects just as a result of X Y
or Z that's where you'd see those costs
come come through
so if I average those out when I get an
idea what the budget numbers like they
would have been
I'm just trying to understand what the
jump is if there is one from this but
this cycle to the next cycle
sure
um I I would have to I'd have to take a
look at that can I take a shot at that
is is this is this just something as
obvious as as uh 22 is measured actual
expense this is what you really spent
but if we had put 22's adjusted
authorized instead of the actual I
assume that that number would be much
closer to the 23 authorized adjusted
authorized well the adjusted authorizes
normally just in the second year for
those unspent funds that have been
obligated towards something during the
biennium because then at the end of the
biennium all the general funds would
would lapse so so the the the reason
that that I don't want to just say we
can take one and divide it by the other
is because if there were subsequent
Appropriations that were made if there
were fiscal items that that came forward
before the fiscal committee that were
accepted that were added into that
adjusted authorized that's the that's
the only reason why I hesitate there
that's great fiscal always tells us it's
never General funds
yes
okay excellent moving on to slide 16.
uh you have your Division of Medicaid
services in here in front of you uh just
a couple of things and I know everybody
is probably aware of this the grant
Advantage Healthcare program is set to
expire in December 31 of 2023 there is
currently legislation to address that
issue
there is also the Medicaid unwind and
Henry Littman the director of the
division of Medicaid services will be
coming here to speak with you on that
beginning April 1 the enhanced f-maps
we've been able to receive an additional
6.2 maps from the federal government
that will that will go away and then
we'll have five percent enhanced fmaps
for the end of June and then July
through September we'll have 2.5 percent
enhanced fmap and then uh for the last
for the subsequent quarter the second
quarter of State fiscal year 24 that's
where we'll have the 1.5 percent
now you what you're not seeing here is a
significant number or or one of the
larger increases that we have seen in
the Medicaid Program and think regular
Medicaid think chip uh children's health
insurance plan and then think expanded
medicaid or granted Advantage Health
Care Program you're not seeing the
granted Advantage Healthcare program
figures here because that is in a trust
fund that that that you you won't see
within the governor's recommended budget
um and and we receive a 90 10 a 90 match
from the federal government on that
um and and we do so in state fiscal year
23 just for everyone's awareness and we
are expecting about 590 million dollars
of expenditures but for 24 and 25 we
expect that to drop
um to about 455 and 464 million so the
the expanded population
are the most likely that will be
disenrolled uh beginning beginning in um
in in the coming months and and that's
why you're going to see a significant
drop there but you're not necessarily
going to see an equivalent drop within
within the Medicaid budget that will
so a couple questions one is a quick one
I hope the diff the drop from so this is
going the opposite direction now from
actual 22 to adjusted authorized 23 is
actually going down pretty dramatically
in federal funds but even substantially
in general funds is that you can explain
and if not you can get back to us don't
don't think too hard yeah I let let me
analyze that a little bit I don't want
to speculate anyone give you any
incorrect information so a more general
question this is probably directed at
the for the commissioner
any reason you would be concerned with
putting the granite Advantage program or
the expanded medicaid
um onto the budget and maintain the
existing flow of other funds if you will
trust fund
I I can tell you
I know I would have to get back to you
on that question okay do you understand
how the funding works now
okay it's a whole different bunch of
streams outside of okay so I'm not
suggesting changing that I'm just asking
if it was brought on budget so we could
s do you see it I mean you don't see it
at all in our budget
no no you you you won't see that 90 10
match you you did see uh aspects of that
through the fiscal item this morning
um you know you you will see it through
those additional acceptance expense but
representative walner
I just wondered if you could remind oh
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I just wondered um if you
might remind us where the 10 our match
comes from
uh for that program
sure
um So currently there is a um
a portion of it comes through
um I'm drawing a blank on the name here
the insurance premium tax pays for a
portion of it and then liquor funds are
also used to to pay for a portion of it
and for this particular biennium
um there there was a house bill 2
language to allow us to go if there was
a shortfall particularly given the
increased populations because we have
not been able to disenroll individuals
from Medicaid in order to continue to
accept the enhanced fmap we have had to
go and use that that language to request
additional liquor funds in 22 we
requested an additional 8.7 million
dollars in liquor funds to cover the the
10 side in this current year we've
requested 7.2 million dollars based on
projections
you can pick up where you were of course
if you turn to slide 17 uh this is the
division for children youth and Families
um you will see and and maybe I'll just
uh address this the you will see a
general fund increase there from one
year to the next
um now now this is an area that is
Personnel we have more Personnel in this
area and we did have some supervisor and
cpsw salary enhancements that were
approved by GNC this year in order to
make those positions competitive uh
because we were having challenges uh
retaining and recruiting individuals
um that's part of what what you're
seeing there we also have had the
experience of hiring individuals at more
than step one so in the classified
system there's a scale step one two
three four five six seven eight nine
um
yeah
nine steps and we've we've often in
order to be competitive in order to hire
people we've had to hire them at step
five or even step six or higher
sometimes whereas when we budget we will
budget at step one
um and and that explains some of the
fluctuations that you will see there
um we did we did have a prioritized need
that I don't necessarily anticipate will
be funded for the residential uh
residential provider rates we did
convert to angio ribsum the director of
dcyf will be here in the coming weeks to
talk about this in a little bit more
detail we did convert to a new
Contracting methodology and we have been
working with the with the residential
treatment providers on those rates
um
and and those residential providers to
your earlier Point uh chairman of words
it they've had challenges hiring as well
and and this prioritized need uh was
originally intended to help address
raise those rates so that the
residential providers could increase
their Staffing and increase their
capacity as well
um just another item there on the bottom
so you use Services Center
um
the currently there is an HB I
anticipate anyway I haven't seen hb2 yet
but I would hope and anticipate that our
city new Services Center budget would be
included in hb2 it was done like that
during the prior biennium when the March
uh the the March 2023 deadline was set
for closure of the facility which has
since been repealed through the passage
of Senate bill one from the 2023
legislative session so those are two
highlights for that area so so we
complicated all that for you
um but what what I wonder
is
um
now that now that you have the green
light to go ahead and have an operating
budget for the the next biennium
um do you do you have numbers that
you're already ready to request for us
to put in I guess we have to put in an
hb2 because there's no sununu Center
structure in the budget so it has to be
an hb2 item but do you do do you have
do you have a proposal for us to to
evaluate I can absolutely provide a
change request proposal to add that to
House Bill one
okay and is that do we have a sununu day
on our topics list Mr Ripple
you have uh day uh at least one day I
believe a day and a half for dcyf to
come in so you can address the sununu
center there I will say I've seen a
draft of House Bill 2 and there are
Appropriations in there for uh sonuna
Youth Center operations in the coming
biennium of approximately 11 million
dollars per year
all right thank you for that
um I want to ask you about the
children's residential rates now the the
it seems to me that the governor's
request for 3.1 percent across the board
for Medicaid and I realize this isn't
specifically Medicaid but it seems to me
like that could be
too low on amount but that number we
were told came from the Department
3.1 percent across the board to help you
with with Medicaid rates and and and I'm
thinking about these children's
residential rates is is talk to me about
the 3.1 percent where did that come from
is it adequate
so when we when we prepare our agency
budget
um our work actually starts in March of
last year
um and we hold discussions through the
spring and into the summer and we submit
our budget
um approximately mid-september
um and as as you all know we have our
efficiency budget representing the
existing costs to continue services at
these levels and then we have our
prioritized needs budget and when we're
putting our prioritized needs budget
together we're making a number of
assumptions at that time and we're also
looking at okay we're making a request
over here we're making a request over
here this is really adding up
um and so you know the the 3.1 percent
is uh and Henry Littman can speak to
this a little bit more generally you
know when when we're looking at rate
increases you know there's no perfect
figure we recognize that there's limited
limited funds available
um and and the figures that you see put
for worth in the governor's recommend
recommended budget actually reflect our
prioritized needs we had one in the
Medicaid realm another in the um in a
couple of other areas and and I believe
you will see that reflected in the hb2
provision I know he the governor spoke
to that the other day but to your point
of what's the perfect number
um
can I answer in a long-winded way
okay so we we have been thinking about
rates and historically we've you know
you've seen within hb1 or hb2 you've
seen will provide five percent to this
organization or CFI will provide you
know three percent over here we actually
established
um we we established a formal rate
setting team in the past it was only
Medicaid Division of Medicaid services
Centric we've since established within
the department a Medicaid rate setting
team and that team is now beginning to
look across the department at all of our
rates so that we can look at One Rate
over here and say that's at market rate
when we when we do a a cost analysis and
a comparison to other states and we look
at this at this rate over here and that
rate is well below Market
and and that's really important because
a is consistent with the Social Security
Act and and the purpose of of Medicaid
Medicaid funding um to begin with and so
what I I believe what we may see in some
of the language that comes out is is a
little bit more flexibility and what I'd
like to do in the long run I realize the
challenges that you that you all will
certainly have with this is whether we
can use
um a little bit more of a of a rate
setting methodology that that is based
on Market rates instead of a system
where there are winners and losers
because what ends up happening is if a
an increase is provided to this provider
group over here their stool so to speak
just rows and then these people are
still left down here I mean I I think in
a perfect world and I realize we don't
live in a perfect world we never will
would be more to raise the floor but
raising three percent necessarily across
the board well is certainly a good thing
with limited funds if additional funds
are available whether we would be able
to kind of conduct that analysis of
these areas are lower these areas are
higher
um I mean I I think ultimately that that
would be a good place in a good
direction uh for for us to head
you know so when the governor was in
here the other day he implied
that uh
in order to keep it kind of simple at
the governor's budget level the 3.1
percent went in there and then he went
on and elaborated that
um
that he would he he wouldn't be
surprised if the legislature went in
there and established some higher rates
in some areas and maybe some lower rates
in some areas and and he even implied
you know there are probably some people
getting rates where they're pretty
they're pretty well off in other places
that are hurting badly and I I don't
know if he meant that to be literal but
you know that's that's what I took away
from it so I I do wonder about how we
might go through a process where we can
take a look at sort of where all the
current rates are and at least identify
those spots where we know there's it's
critical red flashing red that we're in
danger of of a of a of a care collapse
of some kind so that we can we can
prioritize that and um do you do you do
you have in your mind a way to lay out
all of these rates that this rate
setting group has been on is it have
they looked at all of the relevant rates
that we may want to look at or just
still a subset
you know I I think it'd be best to have
this conversation with Henry Littman in
the room as well
um I've had offline conversations with
Henry about whether we look at you know
the the the top 100
um payment codes or something along
those lines and really conduct an
analysis targeted at those which you
know would represent a significant
portion of of the rates um or the
amounts paid that are out there so if if
you don't mind I'd probably want to wait
until Henry Lipman is here okay okay so
take away from this conversation that
I'd love to see uh the department able
to uh initiate and lead us through a
conversation about what the what the
right rates ought to be and what
categories
um I I don't want you all to be passive
questions representative
I just have a very quick one for the
Student Center clarification so if the
operating funds for the sununu center is
in hb2 I just want to clarify that
there's the governor has no allocation
for construction or the new building at
all
in the budget
I have not seen the the formal hb2 is
still the office of legislative Services
um
I don't know of any no okay thank you
there is
um 10 million dollars allocated for the
construction of a new facility in house
bill 2. it's appropriated to das which
facility I didn't hear what oh uh the
student I was just curious if
construction
um funds were allocated so you said 10
correct yes thank you
and is that 10 of General funds that
which might be in addition to the 15
million that we've been kicking around
on ARP for a total of 25 million
potentially it only references 10
million of General funds but yes that
could be added to federal or whatever
other source you have okay all right uh
representative Waller I think you had a
question just
when we're looking at the figures in the
Medicaid services the three percent is
already included in all of this right
not separate someplace else where we
part of it is included in house bill one
foreign
part of it would be in house bill one
but the other
um I believe 17 million dollars would be
okay so when I'm looking at when I'm
looking at
um the division of Medicaid services
oh
it's a three percent wrapped in is it
already here no it it will not be in
agency 47. it the the division of
Medicaid services would be within the
hb2 okay
okay so so those funds would
be allocated we were going to need to
allocate those
three percents or whatever decision is
made about them as we go yes okay
there's a they're in a bucket someplace
yes waiting let me ask you the same
question then I've wondered about the 10
for
um employees when we're looking at the
budget
and we see the Personnel line are those
all up 10 percent
no no so in in the
um the governor's executive summary
document that was released in the
Surplus statement I believe he had
notated hb2 45.4 million something like
that in the in 24 and then roughly 55
million dollars in the second year
um so my my understanding is that will
be an hb2 provision but you will not see
that in HP one right now
okay
thank you I want one more and that when
I'm looking at um your
summary Pages here you have
areas where you say prioritize needs
requests I assume those are not you
didn't get those in the governor's
budget
is that correct yes at this point that's
that's my operating assumption so did
you get
is that the only prioritized need for
that in that area that you didn't get
and you got all the rest of them or how
does that
so does that work what I've tried to do
here is highlight some of the big areas
that I'm I'm fairly certain that we were
not funded for um we we did receive a
number of our prioritized needs requests
um within the operating budget there are
some minor technical uh change maybe not
technical I'm using the incorrect word
there but smaller change requests that
that we will certainly put forward to
the house uh finance committee for for
consideration but what I'm trying to do
here is really highlight the ones that
I'm pretty certain are not and are a
larger dollar amount okay
thank you
oh okay so now I I just need to make
sure I understand how to use this
document the hb1 document that we got
from the governor's budget
uh listening to the answer to
representative wallner's question is I
look at a Personnel line
I should mentally add 10 to it to cover
the 10 percent pay raise that the
governor wants in there and then I need
to figure out that Delta and mentally
add it to the bottom line
is that is that
correct is that what I need to do or is
that going to be in a new spreadsheet so
we're all looking at the proposal the
real proposal yeah you know I I would
probably end up deferring to the LBA on
that because typically an hb2 provision
would be represented within the Surplus
statement and you'll have your revenues
expenditures and hp2 Appropriations and
they'll have the table so I mean that
that is certainly one way to think about
it if you wanted to come up with the
exact figure though or make a rough
figure anyway
all right I don't know if you want to
comment now Mr Ripple but I I
it just makes my head hurt to think that
every time I look at a section of the
budget I got to do a 10 calculation in
my head and drop it to the to the total
yeah and unfortunately I think the house
bill 2 appropriation is one lump sum for
the entire state so it's not broken out
by Department let alone by division I'm
not sure if it's as simple as just
adding 10 to say class 10 because you
would also have benefits and some other
costs in there that would be affected so
I'll have to think about how we can
handle that
representative walner
so that that makes me ask another
question is the 10
um actually a pay increase and an
employee will get an additional 10 of
their wages
and then we have to calculate
increased benefits
well to the extent the benefits are
driven by wages so social security for
example would be so yeah so there would
be a few impacts like that retirement
right yes
thank you
Mr chair
representative but just to be clear
those that those will be included in
that lump sum and hb2
I'm not sure I I have to look into it
so still somebody else representative
stream well first of all I'm glad the
increase is 10 and 9 not
9.1615 because the math is a little
easier
but uh um you know I just you know uh to
follow up in the theme of beating one of
these charts to death
um uh the do you do you have a sense of
of um how much Services is increased for
example if there's
30 000 medical visits
um uh you know is the Assumption we're
gonna have thirty thousand medical
visits the next year or is this
anticipating both increase in cost per
visit or cost per uh interaction as well
as of expected volume
uh is that something we would expect to
get through this process thanks
are you referring to to slide 17 I I
apologize
16 still yeah for example uh
um
you know I think you mentioned top 100
codes that sounded like medical uh
office visits and things like that that
would fall under a Medicaid Program
so
you could change the rate which would
change the cost or you could change the
the amount of Demand on Individual
Services so I'm just kind of one looking
through the Looking Glass what are we
going to see
in there all right
you know I I don't know if I necessarily
want to speculate that on that that's
not my area of expertise and that would
probably I I can put a pin in that and
set that aside and just let Henry
Littman know in advance of our Medicaid
discussion
okay so just a question there though um
we know that we're going down in the
population served for Medicaid right in
the next two years so there's that is
factored in there right but in terms of
claims I think is what you're asking I
think Henry would be able to give you
that detail
thank you
excellent
absolutely uh if you turn to slide 18
it's the division of Public Health
Services
um
the division of Public Health Services
is heavily federally funded
um if you look at the governor's
recommended budget there's approximately
74 accounts it actually represents a
significant number of hhs's accounts and
part of the reason for that is that each
of the grants
um that public health receives is
actually budgeted in a separate
accounting unit in order to ensure the
funds are accounted for clear and
transparent
um we did we we did submit
um one prioritized need that that I do
not expect to be within hb2 and and this
was to replace uh temporary funding that
that we had or received to support
contracts for maternal infant and early
childhood home visiting programs we have
received in the past we've received some
governor's commission funds we did
receive some supplemental funds from the
federal government which are going away
which essentially leaves a gap in these
services
um
I don't know if are there any questions
so so this uh let's just look at 24.
there's uh 19.7 in general funds and
77.3 and I'm I'm hearing you that
um this is just an area where federal
funds are really the dominant Source I'm
curious of the 19.7 the general funds is
is all of that essentially committed due
to matching requirements or or how much
of that 19.7 remains a bit I'll use the
word discretionary
to to juxtapose it from us pursuing
Federal money by putting our own ante in
yeah very little
um of the general funds within dphs I
would consider quote unquote
discretionary most of a lot of that is
wrapped up
um within positions that are then
matched with with various federal grants
depending on whether an individual works
on One Federal grant two or three
federal grants
um and and what's allocated to their
particular position
um but Public Health I mean
globally it's it's it's it's a
relatively small amount of the general
funds that the department does receive
but but there's not a lot of
um to use a colloquial term wiggle room
so to speak all right thanks of course
any questions on this we could go to the
next slide excellent uh slide 19 the
division for Behavioral Health
um
we we do have
and and maybe it's just a little bit
easier to address here so you will see
General funds in in 2022 uh were
approximately actual spend or
approximately 43 million
through hb2
um in 23 there was a 13 million dollar
appropriation for child welfare
Behavioral Health Services and there was
also a six million dollar uh
appropriation for transitional housing
which is why you're seeing you're seeing
a pretty dramatic increase year over
year and and uh
7.6 million dollars of that initial
appropriation is six million dollars is
reflected in state fiscal year 24 so
that became part of our efficiency
budget
um so I just want to really address that
that general fund increase that you're
seeing there that's the result of those
Provisions from hb2 from the current
biennium uh just to address that head-on
um the the children's system of care
um
we we did include a prioritized needed
request to enhance the the residential
rates this is similar to dcyf depending
on um the the child's needs at a
residential treatment facility
um that may be budgeted or or accounted
for through Behavioral Health depending
on whether it's a behavioral health
issue or it may be through dcyf and
that's why you see this prioritized need
and I do expect Katya Fox to also
discuss this separately when she be
comes before house finance division
three
so the money that flows through the area
agencies to help the DD Community is is
that in this Behavior Behavioral Health
bucket where where was that that'll be
on the next slide okay yep we also had a
prioritizing request for crisis
stabilization Services as well
um which which I do not believe will be
funded and I know Katya will be speaking
to that as well
the division of economic stability is
your next slide slide 20 and
um this this is the the area agency
agency oh I'm sorry I'm jumping ahead
nope not a next one
there we go
um division of economic stability this
is the team that is going to be
um at the floor level so to speak of
dealing with the Medicaid disenrollment
process
um the the individuals that work within
this division they will be addressing
those phone calls following up seeking
documentation to ensure an individual is
I can either continue to be eligible for
Medicaid or is no longer eligible for
Medicaid and I know Karen Karen Hebert
our division director will be speaking
with you about some of the challenges uh
there and just about some of the the
potential risks that we do see if we are
unable to process all of those
um uh in disenrollments and
re-enrollments in a timely fashion
are there any questions on the slide
before I move on and yes
thank you when you say repercussions
does that mean like National
um
fees or
non-compliance fees or are we more
worried about people not having
insurance and and burdening other
systems well there's there's a couple of
sides I guess to that coin if if I can
have a coin with more than two sides um
but but one side is certainly to make
sure that people who who are eligible
for Medicaid receive those Services
which they are entitled to and then the
the other side of that of course if
there are individuals who should be
disenrolled
um but through an appeal process say
um they they continue to stay you know
they continue to stay on the roll you
know then that has a cost to the state
that we cannot uh be reimbursed for from
the federal government so so there's a
couple of of risks both from you know
both from the the population side of
who's receiving
um Medicaid as well as the cost to the
state
representative Wallner is this the area
where
um
we would find the Tana free Reserve fund
and if so how much is in the tanfreserve
at this point TANF
TANF Reserve as of December 31st 2022 is
approximately 67 million dollars
and that's that's budgeted in a couple
of different areas
um we did have we did have a prioritized
needs request
um for three million dollars to meet our
TANF uh match and and for members of the
committee we have to spend approximately
32 million dollars annually in general
funds in order to receive our 38 million
dollar Federal TANF match and if we do
not spend the full amount so let's say
we spend 30 million dollars the
subsequent year will have a two million
dollar penalty and they'll also give us
two million dollars less so if you're
short two you're actually the subsequent
year you receive four million dollars
less than federal funds there's also a
work requirement
um that that instead of having our match
be at 34 million it's at 32 million
and if 50 of individuals that are
receiving TANF or less than uh do not
are not actively I I I'll have to go
back and double check this but are not
actively engaged in work or searching
for work I don't know the specifics off
the top of my head
um we would then have an additional
penalty that could be applied to that so
there's just a couple of factors when
we're talking about uh TANF to be aware
of so so we have some new people I
should ask you one of you to spell Tana
for us and and what's it mean and what's
it try to do sure uh temporary
assistance for needy families is is the
the federal term
um do you know a lot about the program
aspects of it I'm not as familiar well I
think we'll get the detail when folks
come I mean it pretty much is providing
that financial assistance for folks who
fall below a certain amount of the
poverty poverty level
um I I did want to ask a question though
that the 66 million you were asked you
were asking is it in here it's not
necessarily in the division economic
stability rate it's spread out into
different yes I'm not sure if that was
clear
so as we go through the budget you'll
point out to us where the TANF Reserve
funds are being used yes okay thank you
questions so good all right I think
we're ready for 21. all right
um the division of long-term supports
and services uh
so a couple of things that that I think
are really important to know about this
division
um there are two accounting units within
this division that I expect will spend
quite a bit of time on
um one is 2152 and that is for nursing
home payments and so when we talk about
the county cap which I'm sure we're
going to be talking about a lot
2152 is that account there's about 326
million 342 million dollars budgeted
within that account the second account
is the DD account and that's 7 100.
um that is an account that that is
budgeted at approximately 414 million
417 million
um and and and I know
um the committee has already had
discussions about the the DD system
changes
um in in recent times but but this is
certainly uh I expect this to to come up
during the budget process
um we the department has been working
for well over a year now and change
on making changes to the the payment uh
system that we use uh within the DD
system with the area agencies we've been
on a corrective action plan for
approximately five years now
um and and we've been making progress
towards rectifying but basically what
the issue has come down to is
historically
um we've been the area agencies have
been billing on behalf of the providers
and taking a piece of that uh to to
cover administrative costs and so
historically
um the public and and and the finance
legislature hasn't been able to
necessarily determine what portion of
that is being used for administrative
costs versus what portion of that is
being used for provider costs
um the system that that the department
Melissa Hardy she's the division
director for long-term supports and
services will be speaking to is is to
establish an administrative rate to to
pay the area agencies to cover costs and
then have the provider which were
historically and continue to contract
with the area agencies for those
services to direct Bill the state and
we've been working on a number of our
contracts to make sure that during that
transition period
um you know if the area agency has to
Bill during for a certain time frame
they can still do that or if because if
a provider fails to register for
Medicaid we want to make sure that that
you know the system doesn't
doesn't experience any significant
interruptions so I do expect to have
some fruitful conversations there so so
in direct billing one of the feedback
I'm receiving from the community in
general the area agency specifically is
that the I.T systems to support direct
billing are just not out there and and
that they're freaked out over a one July
implementation when they don't have an
I.T rollout to support the change it to
what extent do you think that's accurate
I I don't necessarily I can't really
comment on the I.T support what I can
say is every other provider in the state
uses the the system
um and and I know there's been extensive
engagement at last count there are about
250 telephonic or Zoom plus in-person
sessions that have been held with the
area agencies providers in other
area agencies are billing us now so they
have the capacity to do that now so the
providers we've been working with the
providers to be able to do that if they
can't get it um get the in place in time
the area agency can still bill on behalf
so I assume from the name direct billing
that the end state is that if I'm Dr
Edwards providing care to a client then
I do direct billing I go from Dr Edwards
straight to DHHS to get reimbursed and
bypass the year okay what so what what
do you imagine the um the maturity time
on that to be that transition is that a
year transition two-year transition will
never get there oh I think we'll get
there there's been a lot of work over
the last year and a half to get there
and I think we will land around July 1st
for some to uh well I should be for all
to be able to do that I think when we
get to the Melissa Hardy can talk in
detail to you about what are the pain
points or potential limitations to
hitting that but right now we're on
track to to meet that implementation
date
okay would one of you just very quickly
describe conflict-free case management
and what do we intentionally have a
conflict enhanced Care Management now
that's a little bit of a joke
so um the the difference there and again
I I think Melissa Hardy can speak to
this much more
um intelligently than I can but an area
agency currently may be providing client
services and then maybe coordinating
provider Direct Services and CMS
regulations requires that there be a
separation between those two things so
the the tentative plan is that an area
agency could provide the Direct Services
or the client services to an individual
but could not provide both to ensure
that that we can maintain compliance
with that CMS regulation
so essentially it's ensuring that they
can't do any form of self-referral by
requiring separation
all right
any questions all right thank you let's
go to the next one New Hampshire
hospital is next as we all know New
Hampshire hospital is our our 24-hour
State psychiatric facility
Ellen Lapointe our
CEO at New Hampshire hospital she was
here a couple weeks ago talking about
some of the Staffing challenges uh
particularly with the nursing and the
social workers and that continues to
impact that availability there the
forensic facility Construction
uh when we submitted our agency budget
back this summer we were anticipating
that we would have an opening in
mid-july of 2024
um as as Ellen explained last time we
have uh based on on some of the
architect design work that has been done
additional remediation work will need to
be completed on the site because as
anybody that's been over there it's a
very wet area
um and given the current climate in the
construction environment we are we are
not anticipating an opening until until
mid-2025 at this point in time so you
you will not see any any staffing
currently budgeted in that area partly
partly for that reason
so
the next slide is Glencliff home uh
glencliffe home
um as I indicated earlier is about 100
about almost 170 individuals that that
work there and provide services they've
experienced some of the same Staffing
challenges
um as well additionally if you've ever
been to Glencliff home it is in a very
remote location it is quote unquote Off
the Grid
um and it's it's not necessarily easiest
to get to which presents labor market
challenges for them we do have a lower
census than we have historically had
as a result of that we we project that
we're going to be bringing in lower
patient Revenue than we have
historically received
um we we we originally submitted a
prioritized needs request for
approximately 1.1 million dollars which
is the difference between our our
current projections
um the general funds that are
appropriated and the other funds or
patient Revenue that that we would bring
in and that's 1.1 million dollars in
each year
representative I can you remind me why
this doesn't qualify for federal funds
I'm sorry what can you imagine why this
the Glen Club Farm doesn't qualify for
federal fund there's no match there
I
let me get back to you on an easy answer
I I don't want to misspeak
sure
I do know that there are no federal
and finally on the subsequent page slide
Hampstead Hospital Residential Treatment
Facility as you all know we acquired
Hampstead Hospital
um back in June 8th uh the the sale was
finalized and the state took over I
referenced this earlier we are we are
seeking to convert 21 currently
temporary full-time positions to
full-time authorized positions
and the the positions that
that that we do have there these are the
unclassified positions only which were
formally approved
you will see a a slight decrease in um
or maybe not a slight you will see a
decrease in general funds in the second
year we're still working on our on our
analysis of revenues I believe I spoke
about this last time when Hampstead
presented at this point in time we don't
necessarily have a great history we
don't really have a great history to
draw from to project revenues right now
the way that it's budgeted we are
um hoping anticipating for more patient
revenues than than um than in the first
year which provides a buffer because we
do have a number of unknowns because
we're not able to use the prior owners
financials to predict our own our own
situation given a significant change in
operations
um and and the methodologies that were
used that we're using so
representative walner
so just to follow up on
um representative Earth's question I
both New Hampshire hospital
glencliffe home and Hampstead none of
them have federal funds
does it have anything to do with them
federal funds are not available for
I believe any of the medic Medicaid
funds
at New Hampshire hospital or like the
dish funds those would actually come
through as other funds within that line
so they wouldn't be they wouldn't show
as federal funds there okay but but
again I I just want to go back and and
get get a better answer for you okay
thank thank you sure
what's what's the process on positions
when you're seeking to convert 21
full-time temps to full-time authorized
what what is what's the process for that
because I I I've been curious about if
if this committee has any influence on
that or not and I've never actually seen
an action that I recognize as as doing
this
so so in normal normal time so to speak
beginning in February and March we we
submit to the governor's office we say
okay we have these positions that are
currently temporary full-time we'd like
to convert them to permanent authorized
positions so they'll show up before you
within the recommended Governor's
recommended budget
because of the
really unique acquisition and nature of
of Hampstead we did not have that
opportunity through this this prior
process
um and and I defer to to the LBA on
whether something like this has occurred
in recent times as far as conversions
temporary to full time
yeah
um I'm not sure I'll have to check into
so so these are 21 temporary positions
that are part of Hampstead Hospital and
not the residential treatment facility
or those one in the same what's the
distinction here
because today's the first time I've seen
the the two things appended to one
another like that
they're one in the same yeah it's one
long name Hampstead Hospital Residential
Treatment Facility so those 21 positions
got caught up in this weird period of
time that need to be fully converted
over so that their state full-time
positions in addition to the sixth
unclassified
okay so that's just the same name that's
one long name got it
uh anything else for us
uh no that's that's it at this point I
was hoping to speak to hb2 but we don't
yet have a copy of that so can't really
have a personal discussion so let me let
me play something back to you to see if
this makes sense to you you've provided
us with your contact information
and I would like to reserve the
committee contacting you directly for
really urgent things and those urgent
things will happen as we get closer to
our drop dead date in the committee and
as a as a as a standard operating
procedure for the committee if you have
questions that you think Mr White can
answer please please send them to Mr
Ripple and let Mr Ripple be the the
broker so that there's some sort of
communication and flow control taking
place
is that is that okay with the people I
just named Mr White Mr Ripple and
okay all right
um I I I want to I want to go back to
basic strategy which goes to the idea of
how do we Define what the the biggest
challenges are facing our state and I'll
run for you what I I see is sort of the
biggest challenge the the thing that
keeps me up at night and and maybe you
could give me some feedback on this but
um
what I'm seeing is that we have a
problem with our clinical flow that that
we have bottlenecks in emergency rooms
where we're feeling filling emergency
rooms
um and keeping people there for
prolonged times because there's capacity
issues in that particular institution
and then on the back side we've got an
inadequate
catcher's mitt for the patients to get
stepped down from those Ed base or those
hospitals with Ed base
that we don't have a catcher Schmidt to
send them closer to their home
and so
so what I think is maybe the biggest
priority of the state from a systems
perspective and this is bigger than DHHS
I think but
how how do we
fix that flow problem what what do we
need to do to make sure that the
catcher's mitt is big enough
to allow a flow out of our hospitals
it's a it's a huge issue right the
system is clogged everywhere right on
the front end and on the back end so in
any given day we have people in our care
that are ready for discharge but have
nowhere to go
there's places for them to go but they
don't have the beds because they don't
have the staff
right so we build a children's system of
care we have programs but yet we can't
open up every bed in every program and
level of care because they don't have
the Staffing
so it's the thing that keeps me up at
night as well is that we have people in
care that maybe don't need that level of
care and then we're people needing to
so we agree on the problem I think so
what do you what do you see us needing
to do in the next year or two to make it
less of a problem
what what's like the key driver we've
talked about changing the reimbursement
rates for Medicaid and for other rates
on the belief that if we pump more money
into the provider side of the equation
they'll be able to acquire more manpower
which will open up more capacity I think
that's the general assumption that we're
working with here is that is that the is
that your assumption that if we can
increase those rates we're going to draw
Manpower from somewhere to expand the
capacity
I mean rates are definitely key right
they need to be able to not only pay the
staff but run the facility right and do
what they need to do I think it's also
in some cases we may we may need some
additional Services when we think about
drf beds we probably can relieve a
little bit that way but that's not going
to core systemically change it like the
like rates would
and community-based Services I guess as
well I mean are there other when we look
at the cans assessments that we're doing
we think about trying to keep kids out
of the system it's can we provide how
many of how much Services can we provide
in the community without having to have
it be in some of these systems and have
those systems when I say systems
programs service those populations that
need it the most and trying to keep most
people out of that that array unless
it's absolutely needed so it's it's kind
of like fixing the system that exists
now but also building up like when we
think about mobile crisis right that was
a relief in the sense that it was able
to go out to people but now it's still
not enough right we need we need to
increase that capacity and that's one of
the things that I mentioned was
increasing that behavioral system Health
System access so it's there's multi
pieces to it it's not just rates I mean
it is about making sure the services are
provided to the right people in the
is there any room to get capacity by
playing with
um oh there's a term of art for this
where each type of health care provider
has a standard of practice I think
that's a standard of practices uh can we
do anything with standards of practices
so that we can still provide some
quality to our patients but just get
more capacity into the system by
accepting you know perhaps less trained
Health Care Providers into the system
well I mean when we think about
um
some of the work that some of our
providers have done with Workforce right
what are some of the things that are
holding people back from being able to
hire staff licensing right reciprocity
being able to have people come from over
and not have to go through all this red
tape to be able to provide services so
somebody have a question representative
Wallner
well
when I think about the the whole
situation I think about
how much emphasis are we putting on
prevention
because at some point we're paying for
all the high-end Services I mean we are
spending millions and millions and
millions of dollars on those very
high-end services and if we could get to
the point where we were preventing
really worked like with families young
children people before they get into the
system and we I think we would be able
to really avoid some of those higher
those higher cost programs so I don't
know how much is in this budget from the
Department around prevention but that's
where I that's what I always go to how
do we how do we sort of stop what we're
how do we stop We Can't Stop what we're
doing but how do we at least invest in
prevention so that the Next Generation
won't have all of these issues
I think you'll when you when you hear a
lot from DC wife about the work that
they're doing a lot of that work is
prevention is getting getting before
they get to a higher level of care and
keeping them in the community or if they
are getting to a higher level of care
right our children's uh behavioral
system is built that the reason of the
five levels is so that we don't have
somebody in a need that they don't need
but that they could go down and go back
into the community right it's sort of
like that safety net
um not a long-term solution right it's a
point in time of of service and
treatment
anything else
all right any questions here we got
people in the audience who've been
listening to anyone feel the compelling
need to speak up and say something share
something
all right so
um
rep commissioner do you have any last
words I I want to thank you this has
been two hours of your time and then
fairly intense and Mr White thank you
very much thank you
okay so so if you'd like to leave your
your free free to go thank you yeah and
and for the division I think I just have
uh 60 seconds worth of stuff
um we we we distributed uh or can we
distributed the list last night I think
of all of the scheduled events Mr Ripple
came up with that uh today I think Janet
has converted it more to a calendar have
you all seen this calendar is this an
email
okay this is this is what I've been
hoping for I really like this so so if
you'll notice she kind of stopped on
March 1st she's she's no she knows she's
working on the March calendar too so so
we'll we'll be able to see them March
all the way into the sea here when we
have to say goodbye to hb1 to the Senate
but
um
uh has has as a reminder is everyone
given Janet their 20 bucks so that she
can buy
goodies okay super just an
administrative task Mr Ripple you have
anything for us we're going our next
meeting is Tuesday right your next
meeting is Tuesday and you'll hear about
the budget for the commissioner's office
um and you'll deal with most of the
commissioner's office and then Friday
afternoon you'll come back and deal with
the rest of the commissioner's office
um and then Wednesday and Thursday you
um that's what's up for next week
I can just going back to a conversation
that was held earlier I've received
confirmation from Mike Kane that the
appropriation in House Bill 2 for the
pay raise doesn't does include uh
payroll benefits so that is in there
and one other thing is
I can hand out this summary of
Appropriations contained in house built
2 since I don't think you'll get the
actual document until sometime
next week or possibly later but we have
gone through and looked at the
Appropriations so these are the ones
if you while you're walking around
um
do you have any idea who's going to come
talk about the prescription drug
Mr chair
representative I have also asked that Mr
Ripple set up a visit to the sununu
center and invite Finance education HHS
and public works as other committees who
might be interested in seeing the
are you speaking specifically when we
talk about Sanu Center in the budget or
we still have HP 49 we need to dispose
of and technically those are two
separate things that are sound a lot
alike
understood no just so people who are new
to this right who have never been there
don't know what the facility is don't
know what they do oh you're asking for a
tour tour oh I miss that word that's a
key word okay and and what kind of
response have you gotten I just asked oh
okay
so expect it at some point right there
will be a notice that I would like you
to send out to everybody right regarding
a potential site visit I I think that's
a great idea we did that two years ago
and and it changed it changed my world
the way I looked at the whole issue
became very different so we need to go
walk the terrain uh representative
tolorski with that it doesn't have to be
in the near future
um I know there's going to be a lot of
discussion about the Men's prison coming
up in the next couple years and I think
that's something that would be a
worthwhile trip for down the road
so we did one of those as well and we
can ask for another one because we have
new people so yeah that's a good idea
and it's incredibly depressing to go
into the Men's prison it's just it's
nasty because it uh leaks in weird
places and because it's a prison you
never know what where the moisture for
what Puddle came from so it's just it's
just it's just nasty and disgusting it's
if you're trying to protect my uh
sensibilities I think we should all
benefit from seeing the horrible
um environment that they're all in I I
wouldn't attempt to protect you I would
never uh you know assume that you're not
a tough person but I just wanted to let
you know it's just it's just nasty it
you may want to wear higher pants that
day in case it you know so it doesn't
drag but
um all right I anything else for us
no but director ribsum did ask I've
already asked him about a tour and he
was wondering when you would want to do
that during the during the budget
deliberations or after well here's the
deal it's it's the the visualization is
a lot more useful if people see it
before they look at the numbers I think
so so it's again one of those sooner is
better than later and it's probably
should have been something I thought of
prior to this the budget being released
but but I I would prefer sooner rather
than later
if if I were to say something goofy like
heck I I'm available on weekends is
there an immediate no never or not on a
weekend
by anyone
because our schedules are filling up
right
sorry squeeze the rest of life in in
committee work around how sessions
becomes really difficult right and then
my other committees keep me busy I'm
sure everyone's busy so what how do you
react to that Mr Ripple I can ask if the
department is able to give a tour on a
weekend
okay I'm just looking to before is there
a half day somewhere that we could
squeak in a early start or a go a little
Friday towards closer to five well maybe
they'll let us sit down in their
cafeteria and have a breakfast with uh
we we had been leaving Fridays open this
coming Friday you have uh you have
presentations but I don't think you have
one for the following Friday so we could
try that okay I I I have an oversight
committee at some point okay HHS
oversight out all right I'll let you
know which Fridays I know I can't do
all right but I've been there so I guess
you guys can go without me I just like
seeing that stuff all right
anything else
all right turn your mics off and we're
done